as Disney found its Goku already
following a reports that a Dragonball
live-action film is an early development
of Disney comes the news that the studio
may already have their eye on a
candidate for the film's leading role
Liu deal in who appeared in last year's
Aquaman this news bite comes courtesy of
the rumour mongers over at we got this
covered though so take it with grain of
salt
Lin is reportedly being considered for
Goku the good-natured and formerly
monkey tailed extraterrestrial warrior
in the highly popular Japanese manga and
anime series of the same man WG TC is
reporting that according to its sources
Lin is currently on the studio's wish
list of potential actors to help usher
in the new iteration of the hit anime
franchise said sources state that at
this point it is just a wish list
however and there's no word on whether
the actor has actually been contacted by
the studio again it should be pointed
out the report is in no way confirmed
and should be relegated to the realm of
rumor until such time as official
confirmation comes down the pike Lin has
slowly seen his star rise over the last
several years starting with his role as
Zack the cocky adrenaline seeking black
Ranger in the Lionsgate reboot of the
beloved and campy 90s Power Rangers
franchise the film underperformed at the
box office but Lin's prominence on the
project helped propel the Chinese
Canadian star into the spotlight
soon after he appeared as Captain Merc
the leader of Atlantis is frontline army
and Aquaman he then turned up in a crazy
episode of black mirror fighting Vipers
before nabbing the role of Liu Kang and
New Line Cinema's upcoming Mortal Kombat
reboot which is slated to hit theaters
sometime in 2021
according to W gtcys sources the new
Dragon Ball flick will have an
exclusively Asian cast and sport a large
budget a decidedly different approach to
bringing the beloved animates at big
screen and 20th Century Fox's 2009
adaptation directed by James Wan and
written by Ben Ramsay Dragonball
Evolution was universally blasted by
critics and fans alike for its poor
writing weird fight sequences and
whitewashed cast the film had a budget
of 35 million dollars and made about 55
million at the global box office making
it a pretty egregious flop especially
for such a spectacular ly popular
property I am the hope of the universe
[Music]
I am the answer to all living things
that cry out for peace there are a few
new franchises as popular worldwide as
Dragon Ball heart heroes dirty heart
super-powered action story heart tale of
friendship the cultural influence of the
anime has stretched far beyond its
humble beginnings as a serialized manga
which was first published in 1984 since
its initial incarnation the Dragon Ball
franchise has spawned a number of manga
spin-offs several big and small screen
anime adaptations theme park attractions
a series of soundtracks hanyan books
collectible cards tabletop games video
games and even a pop-up cafe with all
that to its name it shouldn't be
surprising that it's one of the
highest-grossing media franchises of all
time and one that major studios
definitely want to try to cash in on
following the catastrophe that was the
2009 live-action adaptation though it
seemed highly unlikely that Goku and his
unforgettable enemies would ever see the
light of live adaptation again knowing
how badly it could go wrong
some of dragonballs most die-hard fans
even started to believe that no film at
all was better than another bad luck
thanks to the Disney Fox merger earlier
this year however everything has changed
Disney has become an absolute juggernaut
for producing high-value ip-based
franchises the studio that managed to
assemble Marvel Star Wars and Pixar
under its roof before moving on to Fox
has been so successful in converting
established IP to box-office gold that
it's got other Studios scrambling to
figure out how to replicate its model
with their own projects Fox Studios has
seen many of its in development movies
scrapped since the merger but that
doesn't mean that the mouse house isn't
interested in welcoming fox's more
powerful properties into the fold with
Dragon Balls massive cultural clout it
seems highly likely that Disney will at
the very least consider bringing this
beloved anime universe to life until we
get some kind of actual announcement
though we'll just have to hope that
there's something to all of the buzz and
for our money Lynn would make an
absolutely amazing Goku we'll keep our
eyes peeled for any official word and
keep you up to speed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]